vous retrouverez bientôt au grenier à
sel percu jam percute j'aime ça sera
vendredi 14 décembre à 20h45 c'est la
projection d'un documentaire sur le
groupe de musique perd plus jam
musiciens c'est exceptionnel
il s'agit dans les deux musiciens
autiste qui viendront sur scène après le
film c'est un partenariat avec la merise
des réservations se font sur le site de
la mairie ce point commun est le
deuxième événement au grenier à sel ce
sera mardi 18 décembre à 20h45
c'est jean-paul go qui viendra premier
un tas d écart infime sur un jeune
marocain qui découvre la cuisine avec sa
grand mère et qui vient en france
rencontrait des grands chefs
mais bien entendu il fera l'expérience
du travail précaire
l'expérience de l'immigration
clandestine
des micros et tout ça se déploiera cette
rencontre se fera en partenariat avec le
mois donc ce sera mardi 18 décembre à
20h45 pour grenier à sel c'est que kita
des zones habitées
un plaisir actifs
le couscous on peut perdre
[Musique]